renee is in san jose hi renee how are
you
good afternoon gabe thank you for taking
my call sure what's up
i'm 47 years old and i need help finding
motivation to work for another 13 years
until i'm 60 years old
i'm going to try to preempt your
questions i have about 2.1 million
in various 401ks and about 1.6 million
in stocks and bonds
and a 20k savings emergency fund in my
bank
as i said i'm 47 years old i've never
married no kids
i support my parents who are in their
80s and i have no debt
my three houses are paid off and i've
paid off my medical school loans
i make about 200k a year as a doctor and
in the context of my parental caregiving
responsibilities i met with a financial
advisor last year
to ask ask how it would be financially
if i had to stop working
in order to care for my parents in the
setting of covid
and she said i could stop working and
have enough money to support myself
now if i work another 13 years until i'm
60 years old
i'll get free health insurance for the
rest of my life and i can start
receiving my pension at age 60 years
instead of at age 65 years what do you
like about your work what do you not
like about it
thank you for asking i love my job
i love seeing patients i feel so blessed
it's such a privilege
if i had to take care of my mom i don't
know if i could
work at the same time i wouldn't want to
put her in a nursing home because then i
wouldn't be able to see her
you don't need motivation to work for 13
more years if you love everything about
it
what is it you don't like
what do i not like well work is
overwhelming these days in the setting
of covid
um i always work more than my paid hours
and i
accept that um if i
truly didn't feel the need to work i
might
go to medical uh sorry music school i
i play the piano and the violin and it's
always been a dream of mine to
apply to a music conservatory
yeah you know renee here's the deal
you're a renaissance woman yep
3.7 million dollars you're a doctor and
now you want to go to a music
conservatory
is there anything this woman can't do
you're amazing yeah everybody's going oh
i feel a little bit worse about myself
including me
but renee you know dave's right you
don't need motivation
you need a mission and i think you've
got to say it's okay
i think you have to let yourself off the
hook i i just i've heard these calls
before
is there some sense of and i don't want
to use the word guilt in the in the
normal sense that we use it with a like
you did something wrong
but there's some sort of guilt or shame
that you have when you
allow yourself to envision not being a
doctor because you do love taking care
of patients
but you've got this other side of you
that that you'll want to explore is
there some sort of guilt or shame you're
dealing with
i wouldn't call it guilt or shame but
what would you call it
um lost opportunity yeah all right
so if in the next 13 years i develop
arthritis or lose my hearing
will i regret not having taken the
chance of
getting my skills in place and the
answer is trying
i think the answer is yes that's what i
hear what do you think the answer is
i think it's yes you think you'll regret
it
um there's a high chance i would regret
it i mean there are other outlets for
music it's just that our local
orchestras and string quartets aren't
meeting
currently all right let me ask you this
really quick let me ask you this what
kind of a doctor are you general
practice is a specific
type of medicine you do i i'm an ob gyn
i deliver babies
okay that's awesome so therein lies the
extra hours right
you just you just keep delivering babies
i think you're at a position
uh professionally and financially where
you could you could draw
back a little bit and not work as much
as you are and begin to pursue this
practice in half i agree with that and
pursue
that get the best of both worlds yeah
the joy
of delivering babies that you still have
joy from and you love your patients
but you're just doing too much of it and
it's got you boxed out of doing other
things you want to do
cut your practice in half you can afford
to do whatever
you want to do if you're asking us
mathematically you're a financial
advisor's right you could quit your job
and you know you figure out a way to
live on 3.7 million dollars i think you
struggle through here
but um but but i i think you get too
much joy and satisfaction from your
medical career i think you just
structured it
to where it's eating you alive it's just
eating into what you really want to do i
think you do what dave says renee here's
why
let's say you cut back on the practice
guess what there's always going to be
more babies
so you can ramp up this isn't a risky
situation here and dial in a little bit
you know are we gonna have a covet
generation that are all born because
people are at home
renee's the one to ask i think we're
seeing that aren't we renee
a baby boom actually it's the up it's
actually the opposite
um people don't want to be around each
other likelihoods
there is some increased domestic
violence unfortunately yeah i knew that
economically um due to job loss
and uncertainty health insurance loss
we've actually seen
a decrease in the number of babies born
per month
yeah wow okay so people people were
yeah wow i didn't i never thought about
it i just wow
okay so anyway yes i would pull back
i would give you permission to cut your
practice roughly in half or more
the only reason i wouldn't quit
completely is i also think you'll regret
that because i think you get a level of
joy out of this yes i agree with that
thank you for that the three of us are
on the same page so
i used to make over 300k which was my
base pay
and i have given up operating which is
doing surgery on women
and as of last year i did give up labor
and delivery so i'm no longer on call on
weekends nights and holidays so i went
from
full time which is in doctor's world 80
to 90 hours
per week to part time which is about 50
to 60 hours per week
and that gave you that gave you some
relief yeah but you're still going hard
you're still going hard and um so i
don't know what portion of the practice
i don't know how to parse out an obese
practice
um but um i would parse it out in some
way to where you cut back to i don't
know whatever you want to call it 30
hours or
whatever i would keep my toe in that
water though i don't think i would walk
away cold
and and i don't think you have to to
explore the music stuff because as you
said
some of the music is coming back a
little slower
than other areas of the culture and so
i got lots of friends in the music
business here in nashville and
they were kind of wishing that it was
going better a lot of them are
struggling
so yeah this
is the ramsay show